Ciao e bentornato alla serie di corsi sul Variational Quantum Eigensolver.
Mi chiamo Victoria Lipinska e in questo video vedremo come rappresentare
un dato problema VQE in un modo che il computer quantistico comprende.
Tipicamente, un problema di chimica quantistica è espresso in termini di energie
del sistema.
Facciamo riferimento all'operatore che descrive queste energie come l'Hamiltoniano.
Per prima cosa, dobbiamo quantizzarlo.
Cioè esprimerlo nel linguaggio della chimica quantistica,
che è formalmente chiamata seconda quantizzazione.
Se l'Hamiltoniano descrive interazioni fermionic he, per esempio,
l'energia degli elettroni negli orbitali di spin, facciamo riferimento a questo
come Hamiltoniano fermionico, e sarà il nostro punto di partenza oggi.
I qubit, però, hanno il loro linguaggio.
Gli operatori nel mondo dei qubit sono descritti dagli operatori di Pauli.
Il nostro obiettivo qui è quindi esprimere gli operatori fermionici
in termini di operatori qubit.
Esiste una semplice corrispondenza uno a uno tra
gli stati zero e uno per i fermioni e i qubit.
Quindi anche la mappatura tra gli stati è diretta.
Tuttavia, la mappatura degli operatori è leggermente più complessa.
Gli Hamiltoniani fermionici sono espressi con operatori di creazione e
di distruzione.
Quindi il nostro compito è rendere più facile per un computer quantistico capire
l'Hamiltoniano.
Utilizzeremo strumenti matematici per mappare un Hamiltoniano fermionico
in un Hamiltoniano qubit con gate.
In altre parole, tradurremo tra
il linguaggio della chimica quantistica e il linguaggio del calcolo quantistico.
Immagina due catene, una con i fermioni,
il linguaggio della chimica quantistica.
E una con i qubit, il linguaggio del calcolo quantistico.
A prima vista, la mappatura sembra semplice, no?
In entrambi i casi, vediamo sistemi a due livelli.
Per i fermioni, abbiamo o un fermione nello stato
o nessun fermione.
E per i qubit, abbiamo o lo stato 0 o lo stato 1.
Tuttavia, è più sfumato di così.
La differenza tra una catena di qubit e una catena di fermioni
è qualcosa di molto fondamentale in fisica: quello che chiamiamo simmetria di scambio.
Due fermioni non possono mai occupare lo stesso stato.
Per una catena di qubit, invece, è completamente diverso.
Due qubit possono trovarsi entrambi nello stesso stato,
poiché un qubit non è un fermione.
Dobbiamo ora trovare un modo per tradurre tra le due catene.
Già nel 1928, due ricercatori, Jordan e Wigner,
dimostrarono che gli operatori fermionici per l'intera catena
possono essere rappresentati esattamente in termini di operatori qubit.
Questa è la mappatura più diretta per un computer quantistico.
Per esempio, la si può usare per mappare l'occupazione
di un orbitale sullo spin di un qubit.
In pratica, questa mappatura per un Hamiltoniano produce una somma pesata di operatori di Pauli.
Questo è un fatto molto importante, che ti chiedo di tenere a mente,
e ci torneremo nel prossimo modulo dove parleremo
di come i circuit variazionali vengono eseguiti sul computer quantistico.
La mappatura di cui sopra significa che se avessimo, per esempio,
14 operatori fermionici, mapperemo il problema su 14 qubit.
Per fortuna, esistono metodi intelligenti per ridurre il numero di qubit
e usare meno risorse quantistiche per ottenere prestazioni migliori da un computer quantistico.
Tipicamente, in un sistema molecolare, conosceremo
alcune simmetrie fisiche dell'Hamiltoniano,
per esempio, il numero totale di elettroni è fisso.
Questa informazione può essere usata per ridurre la dimensione del problema
senza perdere alcuna informazione rilevante.
Chiamiamo questa tecnica la riduzione dello spazio attivo.
Questo consente di ridurre il numero di risorse, ovvero il numero di qubit,
prima della mappatura qubit come la trasformazione Jordan-Wigner.
Questo passaggio calcola un Hamiltoniano efficace
e ci permette di usare meno qubit come risultato.
Per il nostro esempio con 14 orbitali,
questa tecnica riduce il numero di qubit a soli sei.
Possiamo ora andare ancora oltre con queste riduzioni.
Possiamo usare mappature diverse,
un po' più elaborate della Jordan-Wigner.
L'esempio più comune è la mappatura di parità.
La mappatura di parità non mappa l'occupazione degli orbitali sui qubit,
ma piuttosto la parità degli orbitali su singoli qubit.
Non entreremo nei dettagli matematici qui,
ma ciò che è importante sapere è che questa mappatura contiene
ridondanze aggiuntive che possono essere sfruttate per rimuovere altri due qubit.
Quindi, nel nostro esempio con 14 orbitali, si passa da 14 qubit
a 6 qubit con la riduzione dello spazio attivo e poi a 4 qubit
con la riduzione a due qubit nella mappatura di parità.
Menzioniamo brevemente un'altra trasformazione.
Un'altra mappatura comunemente usata tra la rappresentazione
fermion ica e quella qubit è la trasformazione Bravyi-Kitaev.
La trasformazione Bravyi-Kitaev usa i qubit per codificare le informazioni
sia sul numero di occupazione che sulla parità dello stato quantistico.
La trasformazione Bravyi-Kitaev combina le informazioni sul numero di occupazione e sulla parità
per una base di orbitali molecolari di dimensione N,
vengono usati nuovamente N qubit.
Tuttavia, le informazioni memorizzate in ciascun qubit
variano ora a seconda di quale qubit si tratta.
Cioè, quando l'indice del qubit è pari,
memorizza il numero di occupazione del corrispondente
orbitale come nella mappatura Jordan-Wigner.
Quando l'indice del qubit è dispari, il qubit memorizza la parità di un particolare
insieme di numeri di occupazione. La trasformazione Bravyi-Kitaev è la più efficiente
quando il numero di qubit si avvicina a una potenza di due.
La mappatura Bravyi-Kitaev combina i vantaggi della Jordan-Wigner
e delle trasformazioni di parità.
Riduce il numero di qubit su cui agisce ciascun termine dell'Hamiltoniano,
È importante per la simulazione quantistica poiché i termini
che agiscono su un gran numero di qubit nell'Hamiltoniano
richiedono circuit più lunghi per la loro simulazione.
Questo significa che la profondità del circuit
è ridotta con la trasformazione Bravyi-Kitaev e in generale
possiamo ottenere risultati migliori con l'hardware.
Questo è un miglioramento rispetto alla trasformazione Jordan-Wigner
che produce un Hamiltoniano qubit dell'ordine di N.
Quindi, in questo video abbiamo esplorato i metodi per mappare
un Hamiltoniano fermionico su un Hamiltoniano qubit.
Nel prossimo vedremo come selezionare al meglio lo stato
e una forma variazionale o un circuit.
Ci vediamo lì.